2022 a été une année très chargée en
sciences plusieurs découvertes ont
repoussé les limites de nos
connaissances dans plusieurs domaines on
pense par exemple à la santé jusqu'à
l'univers même qui nous entoure et on va
revenir ce matin sur les événements qui
ont marqué l'année avec le journaliste
scientifique Renault manguerrand a gagné
qui est avec moi ce matin en studio
bonjour Renaud alors c'est une nouvelle
qui avait commencé l'année 2022 on s'en
rappelle cette première médicale des
chercheurs qui ont transplanté un coeur
de part génétiquement modifié
quelqu'un qui avait finalement besoin
d'un nouveau car c'était une première
fois sa première fois en fait qu'on
essaie de traiter quelqu'un de cette
façon là on le sait les dons d'organes
en ce moment c'est les listes d'attente
pour ça c'est un gros problème et des
fois il est plusieurs fois par année
c'est y arrive que des patients décèdent
en attendant d'avoir un organe qui
serait compatible avec eux et on a déjà
pensé en fait qu'une solution à ce
problème là ce serait de greffer des
organes d'animaux qui produisent des
animaux proches de nous comme le port
justement pour essayer de remplacer un
organe malade malheureusement ça
jusqu'ici les problèmes de rejet fait
que ça a jamais été une solution viable
sauf que le depuis les 10 dernières
années on a une nouvelle approche on
essaie d'utiliser des organes qui
viennent d'animaux qui sont
génétiquement modifiés pour réduire au
maximum la réaction de rejet donc notre
depuis quelques années notre contrôle
sur le génome est rendu tellement grand
qu'on est capable de savoir quel genre
on peut retirer quel gène on peut
laisser pour quel genre sont
responsables en fait la plus grosse
réaction de rejet puis on les enlève et
c'est avec cette méthode là qu'on a en
janvier dernier traiter un Américain de
57 ans donc il y avait vraiment besoin
lui c'est une question de jours il y
avait besoin d'un nouvel organe où il y
allait mourir et donc on lui a fait
cette griffe expérimentale d'un quart de
part génétiquement modifié pour
justement minimiser les risques de rejet
est-ce qu'on sait c'est la procédure
finalement à fonctionner elle a
fonctionné l'homme a vécu en fait
pendant deux mois avec ce coeur là ce
qui est ce qui est le record en fait
jusqu'à maintenant ta maman il y a la
c'est bien pour faire la physiothérapie
pour discuter avec son entourage ça
semblait bien aller malheureusement il
avait avant la procédure une santé
fragile et après quelques semaines
tomber malade sa santé c'est détériorer
au final il est quand même décédé mais
malgré tout le coeur quand on a regardé
semblait pas avoir c'est de signes de
rejet donc les chercheurs disent que la
procédure ça aurait pu fonctionner
effectivement dans un autre
circonstances donc là ça c'est un gros
en fait ça suscite beaucoup d'espoir et
on pense que d'ici on va perfectionner
la méthode et d'ici peut-être les 5 10
prochaines années on devrait avoir cette
méthode-là qui pourrait venir soulager
justement ces listes d'attentes pour les
personnes qui ont besoin d'organes
rapidement si on regarde maintenant du
côté de l'espace l'année 2022 qui a
aussi été très riche en progrès je pense
qu'on aurait pu faire toute la chronique
avec cette l'espace seulement il y a eu
le satellite James web qui change notre
façon de voir l'univers on a eu
l'émission Artémis qui signale le retour
des humains sur la lune mais au milieu
tout ça on a eu une autre une autre
avancée un peu plus science-fiction
celle-là pour la première fois on a
réussi à dévier la trajectoire d'un
astéroïde donc ça c'est une étudié comme
opération c'était on aurait pu faire ça
ça ressemble à des films d'action mais
il y a pas de bombes nucléaires
impliqués c'était vraiment juste un
petit satellite qui s'appelait et cette
mission là c'était vraiment de montrer
est-ce qu'on est capable de modifier de
façon contrôlée la trajectoire d'un
astéroïde advenant qu'un jour peut-être
il y a une grosse roche qui vient dans
la direction et compagnie qu'un peu et
qu'on veuille dévier sa trajectoire
avant que ça nous touche et comment on
avait fait finalement mais ça c'est ça
c'est passé le 26 septembre dernier donc
c'est un satellite de la taille d'un
réfrigérateur réfrigérateur vraiment
petit compartiment sa cible qui est un
astérode de 160 mètres de long qu'on
appelait qui s'appelle le dimorphose
donc c'est un impact qui est arrivé à 11
millions de kilomètres de la Terre donc
ça c'est 30 fois la distance entre la
Terre et la Lune ça s'est fait la
vitesse d'impact est faite à une vitesse
de 6 km par seconde donc ça c'est très
très rapide et cette force d'impact là
ça a été assez pour changer la
trajectoire de dimorphose je suis un
tout petit peu de ma force j'ai jamais
été une menace pour nous c'était
vraiment un satellite un
astéroïde qu'on a choisi pour cette
expérience pour faire l'expérimentation
donc on le dévie un peu on le dévie un
peu et ça fonctionnait donc on a généré
une énorme quantité de données avec ça
grâce à ça mais au cours des prochaines
années on va perfectionner la méthode
puis finalement on en a vraiment besoin
on aura cette outil-là
et pour terminer l'année vraiment on en
a beaucoup parlé cette fusion nucléaire
ou fission dans certains cas qu'on
appelle je crois que ça pourrait être
révolutionnaire ça serait vraiment son
échanceux c'est la technologie c'est la
la source d'énergie de l'avenir donc la
fusion c'est l'inverse de ce qu'on fait
dans les centrales nucléaires actuels
donc au lieu de briser des atomes on
force les atomes à se combiner ensemble
et ça ça dégage une énorme quantité
d'énergie ça avait jamais été fait
jusqu'à maintenant et donc ça a été ça
prend ça prend ça faut recréer les
conditions qu'on a au cœur d'une étoile
pour faire pour réussir à faire la
fusion nucléaire c'est quelque chose qui
est très difficile mais une fois qu'on a
réussi à faire ça là on est capable de
produire un supplément d'énergie c'est
avec ça qu'on va faire de l'électricité
et c'est ça qu'on a réussi à faire le 5
décembre dernier au lynx lever Labs en
Californie donc on a réussi à combiner
les faisceaux de 192 lasers à très haute
énergie vers une toute petite cible de
la taille d'un grain de poivre qui
contenait carburant à l'hydrogène et on
a déclenché cette réaction de fusion
nucléaire et ça produit de l'énergie pas
beaucoup c'était assez pour chauffer
deux marmites d'eau on dirait environ
mais c'est pas fait donc je pars avec ça
qu'on va chauffer l'Amérique du Nord au
complet pas pour l'instant mais on a
montré que c'était possible ce soit 60
ans qu'on essaie de montrer de d'y
arriver on n'était pas capable là on a
montré que c'était possible et là ben
maintenant c'est vraiment juste une
question de d'améliorer le rendement au
cours des prochaines années des
prochaines décennies et on devrait avoir
cette technologie là qui nous amène de
l'énergie verte pas de déchets
nucléaires pas de gaz à effet de serre
ce serait vraiment une la source
d'énergie de l'avenir et l'on a fait le
premier pas sérieux dans cette direction
là pour la première fois en 60 ans cette
année ça a été un bon coup et donc c'est
un survol de plusieurs éléments percés
scientifique qui ont eu lieu en 2022 on
se souhaite le même genre des
découvertes et d'avancer pour 2023 merci
beaucoup c'est fort intéressant de vous
recevoir ce matin Renault merci et nous
en parler pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI